the faster drink
it's a beautiful example of musical
expression sounded like a broken down to age
hey Dave okay you're right hmm don't want them to
be black you better keep them open I want you to
pay some attention to this lethargy in Opera Benny
you're seeming a little on your dim you window all
right fine yeah great yo from you I want a little
more sweetness I'm singing sweet if you can't sing
any sweeter than that you better hump and rocky
mmm that's for you and that's what does that mean
well I think it means miss feeling miss feeling
Dani you let me sound a waste of all your mutter
righto obbligato was just a little bit just to
cut over what quick quick Ethan boys play it again
oh you ain't heard nothing yet why don't
we polish it off a little she kidding he
must have a tinny area and we're pretty good oh
I've gotta tell you something this thing must
have some more crescendo he asked me it's
a little bit under sink arrow side you know
what I mean that's you know I'm flipping
here let's have your boys into this number
yeah you see what they don't know yeah well I want
you to reach your happiness now hit that last note
what are you doing here - me - hit it he's gonna
channel my minor give him a pick and sent him home
oh man your feet kid you're gonna draw now
don't let me stop and keep right over her see
it's getting better all the time I will never get
ready gonna wait mark why can I see you next time
are you thinking of quartet with six members
I can signals for kissing moles aloud to you
can't sing at this ceremony you're the best man
I would say that I'm pretty good you're only the
best man because your sisters getting married it
don't mean you the best orator even mean you're
a man yeah we get it you already got it it's
only two miles from the end of the subway and
Jack says it's beautiful we were lucky to get
some cheese the owner promised to be out today
and we can move in tonight don't cry you get
your nose all right come on let's try on this
what is this apiece tavern mighty nice you guys to
go to all this trouble you ain't seen nothin this
is gonna be the most sweet sensations wedding
to Devon you way ever witnessed where's Betty
yeah she's in a room seeing which one the
curtain looks best on you want to please
escort at this wedding I'm afraid they want to
go to society weddings mugs you want a police
escort for sure I'll get it how do you like the
please how does it look Oh looks fine I think it
needs a few more declarations they say what's the
matter Jackie and nervous oh not at all I thought
I would be oh oh bloody before I forget it here
you better take this ring Oh II I just look at
his hand better still [ __ ] oh don't lose it oh
I'll put it right here so you'll lose it if you
put it there there keep it on your finger yeah
oh you won't lose this me wearing gay what are
you awareness afternoon I'm gonna wear my black
and white checkered ensemble you can't wear that
zoot suit there's a serious occasion what are you
wearing Jack I'll succeed oh all right Danny rocky
one good clip you a tuxedo a reasonable facsimile
right on our way mud hey you think I'm wearing one
of the monkey suits with the comment I never liked
em yet and you'll like it okay we got a winner say
is the agent been here with the papers on my house
yet no check you know I wish I was a big aeroplane
engineer so I could buy one of those houses in the
suburbs well out of the steel mug so I could have
bought it I only hope there's anything wrong
with it what makes you think there's anything
wrong with it it's still good to be true oh you
just got those before the wedding jitters you'll
get over that you need a little more experience
you really think the place looks pretty nice huh
oh it's fine mugs yeah I could look better with
some of them pictures on the wall those paintings
was morale not my Rao's model what good do you
guys mean mural oh yeah yeah yeah that's what he
threw me off you know he's done something look
I gotta go make a phone call I'll see you later
okay hey much what is it what those are super
what I stupid well that's a place where you got
no running water you got no trolley cars you got
nothing Oh poor people huh right let's go hey Dave
hey put him back open these little
water that's all put him back
that's supposed to bring good luck
oh that's fine no mug said we got to
keep the wedding on us bidding
yeah anybody got any strength
man look at all of them pretty poses laying there
mister falling out of the truck yeah should I call
him back yeah you better hey mister you dropped
your flowers I guess it didn't hear me shall we
well I guess that sums everything mr. Jibson do
you have the papers the keys to the house and I
hope you'll both be very happy oh thank you
very much well how about the present owners
they moved it oh they'll be out in plenty of
time look for you to move in I hope so after
all it's our honeymoon you know oh sure sure hi
dad I would marry myself once boy will I ever
forget that well maybe you'll have better life I
hope so oh yeah how about the house you say it's
in pretty good condition well it could stand
a little fixing up maybe by the way you're not
superstitious are you what yeah the old couple
are trying to tell me that the house next door
is haunted on it yes but you know how old people
are always imagining things I've recorded a lot of
nonsense well good-bye mr. Gibson if I add that
way the house will be filled with many places
memory but okay here's everything except the shoes
you don't need them do you oh no thanks he's got
his own shoes and this color may be a little
small for blimpy but it's the best I can do my
dad's right Scooby's got a small neck anyway yeah
this is swell what they could care of it too well
to make sure you get it back tonight I need it for
Louisa look tomorrow okay come on rock right Danny
that's not a J nothingness Williams nothing at
all look can I see Betty just for a minute hey
not by do - no it's bad enough to the boobies
bride before the wedding mom just brother was
just downtown and we heard some detectives
down here talking about a mob gonna breaking
on Jack Gibson sweating we didn't think you'd
like any ghetto it's downtown guys coming up
here making a pinch right under your nose I
stayed whose mob is it we didn't get none of
the details who was in a hurry I think he
said it was one of the catchman mob okay
I'll have a couple of men take care of it the
dress is 32 East 33rd Street 32 East 33rd at 5
o'clock pilot come on all right boys thanks
lieutenant we'll return the favor something
hey Sione would you mind sitting over there that
chair is reserved for the
bride's mother okay thanks
damn silly oh you look swell cliffy what's
the trouble oh we can't get this collar on
can't get the color run huh stand back let
me take a crack at it get up on the pack
Danny I put you in a little bit take
a deep breath now hold it mmm-hmm all
right no I thought I told you to hold
what's the guy I'm a loyal driver so
don't give me no opposition just do like
I tell you now pulling your Adam's apple
green I got it hey get him up lemon we like
this muscle right hi mom yeah how's that oh
good how's your voice Danny it's much better
I think oh don't use it that you have to sing
Hey oh it's all in your mind that's not tight
you got lots of room there hey y'all you see that
well look what we got yeah one's gonna pinch it
oh that's beautiful now that's got
some class what's that rest in peace
in loving memory to Louie the lug from the
game we didn't mean to shoot you Louis honest
how did you get that on a street now on a
truck fell off you know that sacral aureus
mu cute take it back okay I think I know
conscience nothing like hey wait a minute
and I suppose it would be any more secular
easily bought it back after the wedding put
it in the parlor wait a second got a week
turn that after a wedding take it away
yeah hold on of those hey that's funny this is
Lois soon what are you doing right we're 'no
student till tomorrow if i can I wear my check
suit with the felt on the faculty I can't that's
a high class when you're gonna wear that suit
right there oh just don't - Louie I know what
children just call it chalk them again what are
you taking a charlatan up move to that house I
did I made one mistake for you but not buying you
from variables don't make another mistake get that
face from Gibson yeah Gibson's getting married
today why don't we just wait your question Mike
August no there's another him with just that
kid I can't see why this Guy'd be any worse
than that house in the Elwood Katzie that's
the word copper was been fried nobody knows
what is young-soon do you do all right I'll
get it and try to use your head get him alone
come on I don't take that off again ready it's
about time to get started somebody's neck was a
little bit too big for the collar but it's
okay now oh well where's the tie the fell
outside says he has to see you you can't see him
now getting married he says it's important who
is he I don't know but he says it'll just take
a few minutes okay I'll be right back fellas
hi jack sorry I've seen you for a long
time where've you been I've been busy I
know you're in a hurry and I won't take up
much of your time I want to find that house
on Elm Street well they'll be great they just
bought it myself I know you didn't know what
you paid for it I represent a party that well
they are willing to double what you gave why
what do they want my place what does it make
they want willing to pay for the answer's no
Oh women you can't take a pride in a house
like that look suppose you tell me what all
this mystery about that house is huh haven't
you heard you know that big estate next door
yeah it's haunted what do you know alright laugh
if you like but then why do you think they sold
it to you so cheap but who live is next door what
do they want my place well let us say that there
next century they don't like neighbors alright
now that's pretty thing don't touch nothing
okay line up like I told you and don't take it you
Christian knows and dim you windows and I
don't want no altercations in the lyrics
we're on a step Yolo go
so you can see why you don't want to take your
wife to a place like that no I guess I don't
she has her heart set on going there tonight
I understand it look Jack there's $500 to find
the deal why don't you take your wife away for
a few days you know honeymoon you have to do
that anyway explain about the house when you
get back if I had more time I want to look get
all about finish till you come home yeah when
you get rid of the clothes a deal right me at
this address they'll get in touch with me place
next to mine huh a haunted house okay okay just
a word of warning when you do get back write to
me don't go out you know okay I'll see you later
a date
I will play with
Oh
uprize the fastest wing
I would are you ready clumpy
dearly beloved we are assembled here today to
join this man and this woman in holy marriage
for as much as these two persons have come
together to be made one in the holiest state
if there be any here present who know any just
cause why they may not lawfully be joined in
marriage I require him now to speak or forever
hold his peace I now pronounce you man and wife
again let me fitness 28 stop a cake
so much buzz about a color is
like not death you're right
beep hey yeah you're right now if you're good
Betty why don't you invite us all over to
your new home we could have a party well
I'd like to very much daddy but well what's
all right darling we're not going out there
tonight anyway not going to a new house
but Jack Wallace well I made some extra
money so I thought we'd take a little trip
first you know honey you know anything about
that cliffy moves to me well a place needs
an awful lot of fixing up you know yeah
I hope you don't mind Arlene oh no darling
anything you want to do is all right with me
322 Elm Street that must be his new house
so he is me I guess we'd better go come on
what do you got man this is right what's the
idea Japan nothing I just had mama the cooking
so it'd be nice song okay give it to me hey
where are those gangsters that are supposed
to be here gangsters yeah gangsters well maybe
he lost the address sir maybe you scared him
away yeah you look like an old time scammer
and until you some diplomacy I come with
the form I graduated in school did you graduate
kindergarten well I skipped Kennecott it was cool
more vanilla Louisan are gonna like this
you shouldn't have sold that nice young couple
of a house without warning them Oh Sarah there's
no you're starting something that they can't
actually prove you know in your heart John
there's something going on in that house next
door that isn't strictly honest but we don't
know positively Sarah why John Elwood how can
you say that after all we've seen and heard in
the last six months no no let's not talk about
it anymore we're out of there and finished with
the whole thing but I'm not finished with
it what are you gonna do phone the police
wait a minute wait a minute they don't ask a lot
of questions and the first thing you know we'd be
held as material witnesses they don't have to know
who gave him the information I wouldn't do it now
Sarah well I would give me the police department
Donna Brady speaking this is mrs. Jeong ji
I wish to reproach the mysterious goings on
at three to two Elm Street 322 L what kind
of goings on oh there's noises and screams
of people going in and out all hours of the
night Oh kinds of funny businesses who
is there speaking this is mrs. Zhang Jie
hello hello make that call
then in Mulligan and O'Brien
well I think that's the place doll is very
cheerful Oh does it certainly do not now can
I get your tools we got a hot night's work come
on glam look at the beautiful flowers and put
ketchup on flowers and it's a pretty big place
with some people in it yeah hey there's a house
down there looks more like a place Jack this
might be my I think so good what's the number
on that house 322 well what's the number on
that card 322 it must be the place that looks
like it hey what are you guys waiting for want a
cigarette this house tonight not tomorrow let's
go where comment wait coming all right you got
all the accessories give me the key the key to
the house [ __ ] you you crazy-looking I got
the address the little detail we overlooked
I guess well let's go home yeah thank you ain't
you got no launcher naughty give me that hammer
by me to put a new glass in there in the morning
hey mugs watch out you might cut your juggler
no matter what you guys you're scared a lot of
babies all right and you want in the rest of
you guys can precede me what's eating you
there's Bobby logs in there ain't nobody
ever gonna find me thank you no worrying you
go your new groom in with y'all cause come
on quit stalling wait wait good doctor
you're a fight well take a look at hit
Jack wasn't kidding when he said this place
to please fix it up look at that Oh Clayton
go straight LAN stone knickknacks no
nut where we gonna get some point of
care about that house next door what about
it this is completely footage what do you
want us to do buy another house oh I'll just
buy the furniture let someone else for the
house that's good the first idea you had in 10
years let's go take a look put that stuff down
look what we do
we'll make that place look like
a million [ __ ] are you working
hey the doors open hmm they
must crush their neighbors
oh this is really nice Lance great whoops
everything what the way put that old house
next door instead of this one yeah I guess
there wasn't enough woman for victory got it
she'll make some improvements over there
with this stuff yeah but do you think we
should really take these things they strike
me Jack and pay for it later whitey I okay
good evening sir good evening what can you
give us a ruin a bat yes that's an old joke
I say can you give us a room or a bad and
he's supposed to say well I can give you a
room but you'll have to take the bad yourself
really would you care to register all right
how does that look mrs. Gibson oh are you
and mr. John Gibson yeah sure look it got
my my draft card Social Security
driver's license Automobile Club
but once the marriage certificate no
thank you I have a message for message
call Chelsea five five one eight apartment
243 Chelsea five five one eight I don't
recognize your number it sounds like a hotel
they said it was most urgent I don't know
well a word for boots right over this oh
come on darling and for everything huh yes
hellowho yes this is room two for three
well this is John Gibson what can I do
for you mr. Gibson it's about
your house this is mrs. John G
Elwood I thought you should know
the truth about what do you mean
well look when we go there I'll take along
a big box a ghost Potter I just wanted you
didn't know that I'd reported it to the police
and they should be out there by now well what
did you do that for well of course I mind I don't
want a lot of cops poking around out there okay
okay well well just forget it all right goodbye
what's the matter darling well mrs. Elwood you
sent the police to investigate the place next
door to our house there's something fishy about
the whole thing I'm glad we didn't go out
there now thank you well I'm not I think we
want to go out there right now right yep come on
darling don't be frightened what's good anything
about being frightened yeah oh you got a nice
hotel here which you're enjoying I say come on
short day all right come on step on it you ain't
get no overtime for this hey Dee my wake up come
on get out of there take that chair what y'all
tell you - thanks ray I got a class on the way out
okay lay it down right here now we got
something - wait wait just don't fellas
not to put up the wallpaper over
there and rocky and Danny you put
up the cratons of Drake and get a nice
and cylindrical let me you can sweep
what are you doing can you tell me I could
sleep not believe sweet get up whatever and
go to work don't go up that rush okay chief
well you're gonna do I got I think I'm the
supervisor Oh what I ought to do stuff
for a kidney consolidation so what good
job and I'll recruit you do it for the next
three months thank you I'll split that one
with those screws what is this and don't
get too much glue on that paper it sticks
out through there makes lumps great not all
with them did you ever dress no houses no
what are those lights can be gone
who doesn't dare it's a gang of kids
they're friends with Jeff Gibson you
know the guy that bought the house
next door the more of your bungling
your stupid school ID I know we're coming
out here oh come on Bruce yeah let me get
my hands on that hey do I have such idiots
around me let's find out the funerals about
I give him the house broken
yes red mom I don't know you
went up it yes ambassdor it's all of you uncle
Oh
well maybe it's way myself no matter the
altitude too much boy yet no no no picture
there he's alive those are lie in a wheel up there
first place it's not a him it to her
please believe me him a minute ago oh
yes seeing thing listen man I've heard
him growl all right take it easy now relax
you've been taking too much coffee what
coffee hey would you get what you get go
Doughboy come on step on it come on Danny
get those doily sons yeah maybe we should have
bought a spirit level to make sure it was even
coffee drinker
in a portly must be awful hot with that : the
first example is slow-motion
I ever seen come on hurry up
lippy with clay statues later get back on
that broom I'm just trying to figure out
where ideas especially sweep that custom give it
to the hole and dust from the wallet
to here yes sweet McLaughlin kitschy
the point
you won't you won't know I'm that
warm why Tony took his coat off he
had it on and took it off he
set this code offer you look
well what do you know what put
back on what's going on around
here anyway you blowing goofy -
don't answer that just go over
and lie down next to screw no wait a
minute let's not have any animosity
yeah are you sure you saw what you
saw sure I'm sure but I try to tell
moms can't back their sweep and I
got a blow in my hand I look up at
little pony's got a corner you're still
like that I turned around in these bed
where are you gone what are you doing up
there Hey look now he's in his long drawn
get down off there I'm gonna send you to an
optimist and have your eyes examined come on
down huh plastic what their and get you out
stab you in one of those horns I want you to
quit clowning fathers wanna quit clownin
oh stop acting like a couple is varicose
vein oh is that like a circle thing I
saw a teaspoon of soy tu tu never down
but come on let's go home virus-like the 40th
you're imagining things it's all in your mind
mine is Betty it's like me I heard it you
think I'm thief come on let's go home we
ain't gonna go no place we're gonna find out
what that was you what you said we're gonna
find out what it was well you guys find out
what it was I'll be in the car waiting right
you wait right there said we're gonna find out
what it wasn't I meant it hey cliffie go play
what am I saying what's that letter yet scared
scared I'm gonna spit enough but I'm not going out
there you wanted while so you bossy let me walk
there all alone yeah my name we get back to town
to give you the Iron Cross for bravery I don't
with a skull yeah I'll go find out what it was
what are you doing the noise
came from that direction Oh ed
I touch the maybe shortcut over there everything
one o'clock and all eight will
know how is not to worry about
let's go home now you're gonna go fight me yeah
you don't kill me come on Roli I'm gonna be rich
well do you see anything nope No coup de
foudre whoo that's a cool a Rasulullah who
said that when I say blue that that's a matter
with you that's just an echo virtual you get
what I tell you there's nothing to be scared
of that's what you think what boys here we go
have they gone yes in the cellar
get them out of there quick open
the door hey give me a hand take a look in there
looks like a fitting threat check another
Tommy out of print fresh how does 20 a lie
what the new order means to you how
to destroy the LA the kids have found
printing press and everything so I take
care of them oh yeah thumping upstairs
to the police the Gestapo did you hear a
good stuff oh no yes - American detectives
hey that sounds like spice yeah do you think Josh
mixed up with him no this is his house Jack would
have got the tools and Nazis I hope not he told
us not to come out of here remember you're right
we had a lot of extra so when he left - where did
he get that that's probably where this stuff comes
in yeah how could he buy a big house like this
well I guess [ __ ] your big man won't be your
punch of right a nose or a stop drooling we gotta
figure this thing out there's no time to argue
your brother will oh I can't believe it I might
be able to face the Boy Scouts I don't see when I
choose your brother what we're only guessing what
are you going to your mind what does anybody else
find that stuff here I know what they think yeah
that's right how do we better get it out of here
well we're gonna take it would you put on the
host next or what hit me hit me well you like
you think I was a bully or something that's
a good idea put it in the house next door
come on move it boy all right watch your hand out
there taking the house aren't they taking a bath
by anything in there nothing today
I was gonna take a look upstairs
voluntarily see the nothing is
read to incriminate us yes sir
come with me
it's okay let and Gibson pilothouse
yes that was a lucky me fake to me
nothing huh oh we've been single downstairs
that door wasn't open before
was it that's all of them we
commend what that door there were
we know it's just this minute group
I sure hope Jack appreciates what
we're doing for him you certainly
should that's just funny law I
closely thank you morning all
down here
hey I got a good idea let's call
the cops what would I think of
prints all over there but the idea you
can get it's not to get any more ideas
let's see if the people in that little place
know anything about it let that door open
hey is Jack and Betty
sure cut them out of a tight spot just in
time well darling is a little love nest Oh
dad wonderful yeah with a couple of cops hammering
at the door I wonder who that is let's have a look
Wow find anything no no there's no
one around here say by the way who
who might you be I'm Jack Gibson this is
my wife we just bought that little place
oh I see oh yeah signals crossed
Jack bought that little house not
that big one I'd go home you're right
better get that press back out of there
well we were sent out to look over that big
place their least I know people we bought our
house from seemed to think something funny is
going on it's probably their imagination you
know how old folks are well we'll be heading back
to the station now if you hear anything give us
a ring Boyle I don't think we will bother
you tonight now good night good night hey
oh let's go
sofa
this is the luck
allowing here we are look it over
that Prez Becker wasn't showing that it comes
r17 mulligans speaking we just look the place all
over there's nothing here but a company leeway
looks a little bad doesn't it can't
understand it there should be more
furniture here God what else
but I don't think it's awesome
even just the way it was now okay let's tell
the law yes I may as well get the grips okay
hey hey oh hey mud what are you doing here
like this what I was about to ask you oh
that's a long story it was make the rate mad
house yeah we thought it was yours we find
foot infested a lot of nasty propaganda
yeah we thought it was sure so he moved
it over here yeah then we found out that
was yours so we moved it back again Nazi
propaganda go up so that's why they didn't
us to come out here why don't you throw on
the police we thought it was yours is there a
hole next door yeah but that ain't yours come on
yeah
get me police headquarters
hello this is 322 Elm Street now send a couple of
men out here right away yeah some but the nappy
yes I know they've been here but to send them
back yes they're gone that's right thank you
they calling the police come on let's
go pick it up all right 17 only car 17
we turn it once - three two - well street
urchin that is all we just came from there
you got to be here in it hope oh he's not pleased
today they are now Monjack okay trying
to call you back what you didn't hear us
there's a lot of intimidating evidence in
that house hey what is this a gag police
was upon a printing press in the basement
a lot of subversive literature all over the
place must be a Nazi hide up talk about
the people seen any signs of them around
little that annoy just didn't see no people
but we better take a look yeah fun of me
we've death
so can you pitch you that unless we have an
optical delusion what's the matter well it
was a friend prescient ten minutes ago just
got up and walked away Oh thinking like it's
a printing press can walk that's right you
can still see the ink that I had from where
we touched it that door could have blown your
hands for the last six months for all we know
come on we better get out of here before we
start seeing things ourselves but it ain't
there now see this thing else we've seen
it press when I roll nice sorta nice that's
what I said disappear something with it taking
it out of here you know I think yeah I'll do
all that thinking around here alright going
to think you're always thinking safe a much
you think that's for mice you'll
never learn nothing weird hey I
bet Natali got that press out
of here be quiet you follow me
nobody here let's go home
come on that's funny now what makes my
cottage I turn them off now that lights
are turning themselves on and off come on tap
go ahead of you along I want to see for myself
but good buddy here hey what's this looks like
a printing press ah so what - so what's that
uh one of these what are these look look at
them same things we all have been telling
you all about what's it doing here that's
something you'll get a chance to explain
man you'd better think fast lookee you
don't think this belongs to me this is
your house isn't it yes but either to
find motion tell him you ain't kidding
and boomerang
all I know is the pressure on your crop I'll have
to take you to headquarter talk to lieutenant hey
fellas Jack come here because it could be Nick
to come into a room all right but this is the
last time I believe any of you Oh Brian beat
it back to the house and go down the basement
I'll look down the tunnel play census I knew
you that you couldn't say that are you kidding
you boys stay with it okay oh yeah I think I'm
gonna gloomy in there let me out of traffic
what's your somebody in there
must be some way to get in
follow me
get ready
make Nothing hey mom what
hey cliffie
thank you go home and get dressed glumpy
look 500 plainly far I'm yeah in shave me
come on come out of it look you all right kid city
the winner a new champ I know
you can do it what a honeymoon
you always got to do everything no hardly
everybody else gets plain ordinary coming measles
so you got a glutton they got German measles
you're picking on me for not you know I'm strict
don't flip you I apologize and remember
you've got seven days more to go